so it was interesting
on the 30-hour trip home
to get caught up on the news in america
because i was a little bit out of the
out of the loop for that week as you
might expect especially the biggest
story which is the effort to punish
cancel and silence joe rogan and it all
began of course with claims that rogan
has disseminated misinformation about
kovid because the people who run around
claiming that men can get pregnant and
that the world will end in five years
because of climate change and that
racist cops are hunting and murdering
black people at random in the street
they're all very concerned about
misinformation
but then the the highly coordinated and
funded campaign moved into its next
phase which anyone could have seen seen
coming
which has involved digging up old
podcast episodes where rogan utters the
forbidden word the n-word
a word which you might hear shouted 45
times in a pop song without complaint
from anyone
but which a guy like
rogan can not say even when simply
quoting someone else
if your skin color is on the darker side
of the color spectrum you can say it in
any context you like if it's on the
lighter side you can't say it in any
context at all
now this rule obviously makes no sense
whatsoever it cannot be justified on any
rational or moral basis at all
yet it's used nonetheless to destroy
people like rogan not because he said
that word
but because he said a whole bunch of
other things that the ruling class
doesn't want anyone to say
it's all a pretense
this is why as people have been pointing
out someone like howard stern i mean
howard stern
for 30 years every day said things that
were far more offensive than any joe
rogan episode howard stern put on
blackface and said the n word at the
same time
on camera
and he's not canceled he still has a
deal with sirius
why is that well because howard stern
has been neutered in recent years and
and now he's convenient he's useful to
the left especially because he's
panicking over covet all the time and
pushing the vaccines
this again as i always remind people
this is not a double standard it's not
oh it's a double standard because howard
stern is not canceled but but rogan is
no it's one standard and the standard is
this if you are useful to the left you
can stick around no matter who you are
or what you say
if you're not off with your head
so they want rogan gone because of his
thought crimes
they can't say that exactly so instead
they claim misinformation and they re
they rifle through thousands of hours of
podcast to find a few examples of him
saying naughty words
all the while
the left-wing mob puts on this act
pretending to be to be somehow uh hurt
or victimized
because of words uttered by a podcaster
who
if they find distasteful they could
simply not listen to
but that's not good enough
the fact that he's allowed to speak at
all the fact that anyone is able to
listen to him causes them deep pain and
suffering they claim
now in the country that i just came from
people suffer because they live in mud
huts
and they drink sewage
in this country people suffer because of
podcasts i've been doing a lot of dating
and marriage advice on this show
recently for whatever reason so here's
some more advice um here's a top-notch
gift ideas this time i'm speaking to the
men in the audience guys it's time to
get your lady something practical that
you know she will absolutely love your
gal probably has enough jewelry i mean
they can never really have enough
jewelry but you know and chocolates will
be gone within a day so get something
that lasts cleaning supplies but don't
get it from just any standard unhealthy
brand that will reek of chemicals you
want to get cleaning supplies with with
our partner naturally it's clean
naturally clean is dedicated to
providing the most effective cleaning
products for your home while reducing
your spending your waste and harmful
chemicals in your home their safer
chemistry solutions utilize nature's
powerful plant-based enzymes to clean
every area of your home from the
bathroom to your hardwood floors to your
kitchen doesn't it sound like something
you know your special someone will love
listen
fellas ladies love to clean it's the
most it's the thing they enjoy most in
life and so give them the opportunity to
do it and they're going to find it to be
very romantic also for valentine's day
so try naturally it's clean now right
now my listeners can get their get their
hands on the daily wire essential kit
stocked with four essential products for
15 off simply visit
naturallyitsclean.com matt and use promo
code matt to save an additional 15 off
your order rogan himself apologized to
the mob in a six minute video over the
weekend
calling his bad language shameful and
regretful and expressing quote deepest
apologies
who's he apologizing to exactly
who is the aggrieved party
who was actually hurt by this stuff that
he said in podcast years ago and which
nobody complained about until now
well that's never explained
because by the way
another thing with all of this
there ought to be a statute of
limitations
if you want to be offended by some by
something that somebody says you better
be offended now
because if they said it years ago and
you weren't offended at the time it's
too late now to decide you can't circle
back around five years later and say oh
you know what that thing you said five
years ago i'm actually really offended
by that i've thought about it for five
years now i'm offended
and if you didn't know that they said it
five years ago
then no harm no foul you survived either
way it's too late
of course i say that but i mean if
you're offended by something that
someone says now i still don't give a
damn
but especially if it happened a long
time ago too late
meanwhile the ceo of spotify daniel eck
sent a memo to his staff for now still
refusing to cancel rogan's show mostly
because it would cost him a hundred
million dollars to do so but nonetheless
groveling and apologizing um uh for
for the things that rogan has said he
said in part quote this is the the ceo
quote there are no words i can say to
adequately convey how deeply sorry i am
for the way the joe rogan experience
controversy continues to impact each of
you
not only are some of joe rogan's
comments incredibly hurtful i want to
make clear they do not represent the
values of this company i know this
situation leaves many of you feeling
drained frustrated unheard
i deeply regret that you're carrying so
much of this burden
burden
what burden
you know i've come from a place where
lots of people have the burden of
watching their children starve to death
while their teeth rot out of their heads
meanwhile the employees of a
multi-billion dollar media conglomerate
have the burden of
joe rogan
it's all an act put on by soulless cry
bullies who are so immersed in their own
privilege that they believe they have
the right to control what everyone says
and hears and thinks they're so invested
in this imaginary right
that they believe they have been they've
been personally attacked
if anyone is allowed to say anything
that they don't approve of
and that's why these people do not
deserve an apology
now i don't know joe rogan personally
but he seems like a nice guy and a
decent guy
unfortunately
these are not nice or decent times
you cannot be nice to the mob of spoiled
brats
their feelings are not important
their feelings aren't even real
i doubt very much that these people are
even capable of experiencing true human
emotion at this point because they've
been faking it for so long
when they come beating on your door
demanding an apology the best thing you
can do for yourself and for the world
and even for them is to laugh in their
face
and then spit in it
tell them to kiss your ass double down
and then triple down and then double
down on your triple down
what good will the apology do anyway you
may have noticed that in the whole
history of cancel culture
in the whole history of public apologies
offered to the cancel mob
never once has an apology been followed
by the mob saying we forgive you
never once
forgiveness is not on offer
they want the apology not for
reconciliation but for victory
they're demanding your submission
they want you to lie down before them so
that they can stand on your face and
plant their flag directly in your gut
and then claim you as a prize
don't give these vultures that
satisfaction spit in their face and
laugh at their fake tears
it's the only way
besides when you apologize
you're only pulling the rug out from
under the people who are defending you
the very few people who had the guts to
defend you by the way that's the other
part about this now i've had the mob
coming after me enough times to know
that most of your so-called friends will
will run away and hide cowering in
silence while the hyenas rip you apart
i've been through that myself only a few
people will have the balls to stand
beside you and defend you when you
apologize to the mob you're cutting your
defenders off at the kneecaps and
embarrassing them
they're spending their time saying no no
defending what you did and and then you
come along and say oh i'm so sorry i'm a
terrible person
you hurt the people who are trying to
help you
and help the people who want you dead
so stop apologizing
these people are not hurt
they're not suffering they don't know
what suffering is
life has never smacked them in the face
much to their detriment
so if you want to help them
give them the smack they need
give them a little bit of the pain they
seem to wish they could feel
that's the favor you could do for them
and for the world
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated